- I don't know.
I mean, it was okay, but it seems
like every single
superhero movie these days
is just an excuse for the
good guys to fight each other.
- Oh, I know, it's like they
think up the lamest excuse
for 'em to be mad at each other
just so they can stage a
big fight scene at the end.
- I mean, I still liked it.
I'd give it three stars.
- Yeah, I'd give it 3.5.
- Well, you mean 3 1/2.
- Yeah, the same thing.
3.5, 3 1/2.
- It's not the same thing.
No one uses decimal points
when they rate a movie.
It's just stupid.
- I use decimal points to rate a movie.
And I just did.
- You know, there are times,
and this is one of 'em,
when I just wanna smash you!
- Well, why don't you try it
right here, right now?
- Oh yeah!
It is on!
(Andy laughing angrily)
(dramatic drums beating)
(thunder crashing)
You just started a war.
- I'm gonna enjoy taking you down.
Wait, wasn't it just day time and sunny?
- Don't question it, Andy.
If we're gonna fight, it'd have
to be in the rain at night.
- And why are we fighting again?
- It doesn't matter!
People pay billions of
dollars to see this shit.
(dramatic chord)
(thudding)
(Conan grunting)
(loud crack)
(audience murmurs in shock)
(audience laughing)
Hey, Andy!
Do you bleed?
(audience laughing)
(loud thud)
(laughing)
Tell the Devil Conan sent ya.
(ominous chord)
(Conan grunting)
(dramatic music)
(footsteps thumping)
(audience laughing)
- I'm gonna hit you bald.
- Big deal, I'll punch you back.
- Oh no you won't.
Quit it, I'm pinching you so hard
that you will forget how to pinch.
- Stop it!
(audience laughing)
(ominous music)
(audience cheering)